pas drôle de boue qu'on a ce soir et
alors ils doivent pas s'ennuyer va
drôlement jeu taper la cloche derrière
varane ses buffets ne croyez surtout pas
cela en rue madame
un vrai risque à 6 vient chaleur la home
est insoutenable
un peu d'air frais ça fait du bien
roddick s'est pas vantée brûlatte
là-haut insipide absolument insipide
leur éternel petit sandwich au caviar au
foie gras
ces petits fours sans esprit non par les
moins de d'un bon morceau de saucisson
table et on redonne un coup de jeune aux
dogues pourquoi il n'y a pas de france
si ça vous tente mavs en attendait mais
vous offrir un petit coup de jaja oh oui
effectivement c'est trop gentils gagnent
en bataille
goulon une belle dame comme vous à brno
inverse surtout que je viens de m'en
tape une lampée dans le goulot
j'aurai plus de chance d'être contaminés
là haut un bon goûter moi ça aurait
coûté il est excellent il est excellent
mais c'est un château roussillon
quelle année vous avez rien à craindre
il est toutefois je l'achetais ce matin
comme quoi à 10 dont le caviar à nous et
je n'ai jamais mangé tu proposes tu l as
là il paraît que ça vous roule sur la
langue comme des petites billes
puis quand on craque de lyon alors c'est
un bon 10 en culotte de velours
je vous accorde que c'est moins forte
que le ch'ti mais la légende est très
surfaite
quand même j'aurais bien voulu goûter
une petite x et bats montella au prince
et me laisseront pas rentrer j'aurais
bien voir ça au bas vous avez comment je
suis ça paie pas le très joli votre vie
vous apportez mal bien monter le col
comme ça c'était pas mal hein sur la la
poche et très original mais ça fait pas
je dis comme au petit clip elle va vous
les voulez mais plus mal étonné wallah
allez vous êtes ravissante comme ça vous
croyez comme ça me laisse trois rentrées
mais bien sûr d'abord je vous accompagne
mais voilà mon fils patrick
je ne me retiens
c'est mortal là où c'est toujours les
mêmes têtes surtout aux mais quand tu es
marié alexandra j'ai largué au pourquoi
mais j'ai deux joueuses est petit je
l'avais mart cette nana là qu'est ce que
tu me suis enclin à patrick j'en avais
marre de cette nana là choc la patrie
que dans marianne mariage j'en avais
marre de cette nana là qu'est ce que tu
me choque c'est à moi qu'est ce qu'est
ce que tu me racontes est à toi est à
moi mais c'est fini on est témoin oui
c'est tout ce qu'on avait à dire ouais
c'est tout ce qu'on avait fait tatouer
de chanter maintenant
j'aurai besoin qu'ils ont comme ça si tu
penses jamais comme c'était prévu alors
avec son tube ya rien fait moi j'ai
l'air de quoi
l'endettement j'ai rien dit je reviens
dit j'avais plein de choses à dire